the Joe Rogan experience there and just
the fact that it's so recent that's
what's really crazy ly talking about the
urban sprawl and barbed wire and things
along those lines mean and it's
particularly in Texas where everything
is almost private property I mean this
giant ranches everywhere and this was
all run by the Comanche 98% of Texas is
unlike if you go one one state to the
west and you'll you're it that you're in
the big land public land government land
states Texas is 98 percent private now
that's a weird thing isn't it it is it's
very strange how'd that happen well it
it happened because that's the way it
settled and and the the public land
states just there was for one thing
there was a lot more of apparently a
sort of useless land in in the in the
western states but anyway yet it
happened and in Texas you're lucky to
get yourself a state park here and there
when you were doing research for this
did you meet with any current Comanches
I met with some of them and I know some
of them some of them are on my on my
website um but as far as interviewing
them for things that happened two or
three hundred years ago that's not
really a sort of a non-starter as a
historian although although the book
itself is based on lots and lots of
interviews with Comanches but of the era
people who this is this was the great
there was some great projects done in
the 20s and 30s with Comanches who
talked about you know who had memories
of the 19th century and so a lot of what
we know with it's in my book that we
know about the Comanches and who they
are come from all of these interviews
and there's a lot in my book that comes
from Comanches but again of the era so
you know I just figured that
interviewing people today about things
that have a long time ago was probably
not that efficient no for sure not that
efficient but still to me it would be
kind of fascinating to see where they
are now I mean the the Native American
reservations in this country have
traditionally been pretty horrific and
it's very depressing and sad and for the
people that lived there just so so
little hope and so little opportunity
and it's it's Oh as you were talking
about before the broken treaties and
just to see them having gone from being
this
edible warlike tribe to being resigned
to these very small patches of land that
are usually not very fruitful not very
resource filled and that happened to a
lot of tribes I mean if you look at the
Comanches the Comanches are pretty small
tribe they're they they're located in
their center although there's no
reservations you know there's no excuse
me
all right yeah they don't have a yell
under the flu they don't have a
reservation there but they they're I'd
say the last number I heard was 14,000
or something like that one of the big I
guess ironically in some ways
determinant factors in how wealthy a
tribe is now is proximity to a major
urban area for example Chickasaws and
Choctaws are in range of DFW so their
casinos there make a lot of money the
Seminoles in Florida there are some
tribes in California who are making a
lot of money if you go up to say some of
the Sioux reservations you know well up
north on the plains they're not near
they just did their their the lands
their traditional lands just don't
happen to be close to urban centers yeah
urban centers and so there's a little
bit of that going on there but yeah
that's they this is just you know we're
where we the US government put the
Indians and and in terms of Plains
Indians and Comanches and Arapahos and
Cheyenne's and Sioux and everybody else
they never wanted to be farmers they
farming was exactly what they never
wanted to do and even if you gave them
160 acres they would they would sublet
it they would rent it out to - usually a
white farmer who would farm it and they
would take a sharecropping percentage or
something but yes so they they didn't
want anything to do with that and and
above all they didn't want to be forced
into a type of life that they that they
had never done before and considered it
just kind of unseemly
so do Comanches have a reservation today
no no reservation oh well the problem is
the way this is going to get into a lot
of detail but I mean Oklahoma they
basically they they in favor of in place
of reservations they gave out in
visual apportionments of land and had
them ascend so where I work for example
where I came from in the East Coast
there are reservations if you go to say
Colorado he'll go to see the ute
reservation or some of the Sioux
reservations reservations all over the
place not in Oklahoma Wow
so they're in danger of having their
culture probably get it erased there
pretty I mean I think they would they
would tell you I mean I want to speak
for Comanches or anybody else but that
they're that they're you know they're
they're pretty strongly organized where
they are they they have a nation they do
have a nation is just they don't have a
body of a reservation but they do have a
nation but if they have a nation they
don't have the same sort of laws that
have a real baby no they actually do so
if you go for example I spent some time
with the Chickasaws a few years ago it's
incredible now they don't have a quote
reservation either but they have they
have little pieces of land that is
theirs but they also have a completely
parallel police system completely
parallel legislature they have parallel
healthcare systems and you can and you
can drive through these parts of
Oklahoma where I don't say Choctaws or
some or Cherokees or whoever they may be
are and there are these whole parallel
worlds they're existing right in front
of you and you don't see them Wow there
yes so no I actually I think they're in
a lot of ways a lot of the tribes in
Oklahoma are doing well but you even you
literally can drive through it and you
you wouldn't be able to tell it's just
such a stunning amount of change that
happened to this continent over a short
relatively short period of time yeah I
mean really astounding and and if you
look at what from from the moment that
the last Comanche surrendered with
Quandt when quanta and the the last of
the starving you have had all the
Buffalo have been killed now and so
they're they're coming in and it's 1875
you know that very year they're old kind
of Maine I guess camping ground would be
Palo Duro Canyon one of the biggest
canyons in the American West up in the
Texas Panhandle and that's kind of where
their their sanctuary was or one of
their big sanctuaries worth within that
very
year white vent already owned Palo Duro
Canyon there was already a ranch on it
it was already private property within a
few years there's barbed wire going all
the way up I mean it this is happening I
mean so in other words you have you have
the transfer of ownership suddenly white
people own the land that the Indians
used to used to be theirs right the
second thing that happens is now we have
the cattle drives just before barbed
wire and then there's only a few years
of cattle drives and then the barbed
wire goes up and this happens with just
breathtaking speed and I mean from
really the moment that they started
killing the Buffalo off in the what
eighteen seventy or something 1871 to I
mean full barbed wire it's just it's
less than a couple decades
[Applause]